guys
this is very very this is very very
simple for me to explain this is very
very simple
it should be simple for you to
understand
reading a lot of this evo psych that i
have over the last few years and all
those books are pinned in the top
comment of all my videos in the amazon
bookstore probably the most useful one
that i came across was the evolution of
desire by david buss
you can also listen to david buss
he's done some interviews in the last
few months because i had a new book out
i'm not interested in the new book i was
more interested in the evo psych stuff
but i saw a long interview he did with
andrew huberman i thought it was great
i'll say this
the most important thing that you have
to understand when it comes to
attraction the optics of attraction
is developing a
shoulder to waist ratio that is it's
called the golden ratio and it's 1.62
and all that means is your shoulder
width is 1.62
the width of your waist okay again so
this this also brings in the reason why
you want a tailored shirt like i'm
pulling it in a tiny little bit more at
the back here with whatever's left just
to you know kind of exaggerate it but
you want wide shoulders and a narrow
waist that's what women like
scientifically proven evolutionary
speaking proven
you know it's the same reason why guys
like a certain waist to hip ratio with
women because
uh there's lower instances of uh failed
pregnancies there's higher levels of
fertility it's it's just a more
attractive quality in women but we're
not talking about women and we're
talking about dudes what women like to
see in men and it doesn't matter if
you're five foot seven or six foot seven
or seven foot seven this ratio is
consistent through all male heights
and the easiest way for you guys to
measure it is easiest way find something
that you can take a a dry erase marker
on i don't have a dry erase this is a
sharpie but just take a dry erase marker
and stand in front of your glass shower
door in front of a stainless steel
refrigerator anything that you can write
on to wipe off very quickly and all you
do is you stand there i'm just going to
face the camera you just stand there you
put a little dot on your shoulder a
little dot
you know from the other shoulder just on
the wall the glass whatever is it you're
standing in front and you put a dot on
your belt line and a dot on the other
side of your belt line and move away
from the object that you put the dots on
take a tape measure measure the width at
the top you measure width at the bottom
divide one in the other that'll give you
your ratio
the closer you can get to 1.62 or if you
can exaggerate it and go full on johnny
bravo's style um
i've had mine as high as 1.7
but the closer you can get to 1.62 or
beyond
even better but 1.62 is the ideal
that's great that's all you got to do
and all that is is broaden your
shoulders narrow your waist eat properly
move more lift heavy weights do presses
do you know shoulder extensions i'm not
going to do like a full breakdown
because everything you need is for free
on the internet you want to build
shoulders how do i build big fat
shoulders how do i build shoulders like
boulders you know you can search for it
right how do i get abs six-pack abs
because that's all you really need how
do i eat how do i eat kino body or
whatever you know just figure it out go
look it up the answers are out there
you